the war on drugs is moving into a new
crisis as violent cartels fight for
their cut of an estimated 320 billion
dollar a year industry the global
production and supply of drugs such as
cocaine are on the right around 18
million people used cocaine globally and
the online world is making the drug more
accessible than ever before Britain
Spain Australia and the United States
consume the most cocaine but a higher
percentage of our Bay Niaz population
used the drug than any other country
partly because it's a significant
transit country for cocaine poorer
nations in South America are the main
producers Colombia just 34 from the list
of biggest users produces over half the
world to supply a kilo of cocaine that
costs $2,200 in the jungles of Colombia
can fetch twelve to sixteen thousand
dollars in Mexico but by the time it
makes its way to Europe the same kilo is
worth 53 to 55 thousand dollars
organized crime gangs of finding
increasingly novel ways to transport
ever larger volumes of the drug to these
lucrative global markets old cannabis
smuggling routes are now being used to
transport cocaine such as the bay of
Gibraltar were trafficking increased
last year by an estimated 300 percent
self manufactured semi-submersible narco
subs carry up to seven point seven
tonnes of Colombian cocaine to Central
America and Mexico and traffickers are
hacking into the authorities monitoring
systems to avoid detection global
seizures are on the rise but so is
global production of the drug now the
highest level ever recorded
America spends forty billion dollars
each year on the war on drugs it arrests
one and a half million of its citizens
annually for drug offenses and locks up
half a million but it's tougher drug
laws disproportionately affect the poor
and minorities it's zero tolerance on
drugs has done little to curb addiction
or overdose rates which are the highest
in the world a rising number of global
drug users and dealers now turned to the
dark web to buy and sell anonymously
taking the war on drugs into uncharted
territory it's a battle the authorities
can never win
you